examen esta vez vamos a ver dos
ejercicios estilo examen de los cuales
tienen que ver con lo que vimos en el
vídeo pasado con raíces de la ecuación
característica que sean complejas con
jugadas y vamos a encontrar su solución
como eran complejas con jugadas las
raíces eran de la forma lambda más menos
new y espero recuerden eso y también en
el vídeo pasado habíamos visto que la
solución general entonces tomamos la
forma a la lambda x que multiplicaba
hace 1 a una primer constante por el
coseno de 1000 x x más una segunda
constante c 2 que multiplica al seno de
mil x
muy bien entonces con dos problemas de
este estilo vamos a trabajar el primer
problema que se me ocurre es tener la
segunda derivada ya esta segunda
derivada a sumarle cuatro veces la
primera derivada y sumarle 5 veces la
función sin derivada e igualando a 0 es
una ecuación que es diferencial de
segundo orden con coeficientes
constantes y homogénea vamos a poner
también en condiciones iniciales para
hacerlo un poco más entretenido ya de
cero es uno de prima de cero va a ser
cero ya tenemos las condiciones
iniciales por lo tanto también va a
haber que determinar la constante 1 y la
constante 2 pero ahora sí vamos a
resolver la ecuación característica
asociada a esta ecuación diferencial
pues es esta que estoy escribiendo es re
cuadrada más 4 r 5 igual a 0 y lo que
teníamos que hacer después de ello es
hacer las raíces pero esto es una
fórmula general me queda menos o sea
menos 4
menos la raíz cuadrada de b cuadrada o
sea de 4 al cuadrado que es 16 menos 4
veces a que vale 1 y sé que vale 5
todo esto lo dividimos entre dos veces
pero a vale 1 entonces esto es entre 2
bien esta es la forma de mis raíces
entonces voy a simplificar un poco pues
me quedan menos 4 más menos la raíz
cuadrada de 16 menos 4 por 1 por 5 que
es 20 o sea 16 menos 20 es la raíz de
menos 4 muy bien y todo esto lo tengo
que dividir entre 2 pero ahora vamos a
escribirlo de una manera que ya se vea
claramente cuál es la parte real y cuál
es la parte imaginaria la raíz de menos
4 pues es 2 y están de acuerdo es decir
me va a quedar menos 4 más menos 2 y
entre 2 y ahora si las raíces conjugadas
van a ser menos 4 entre 2 que es menos 2
- 2 / 2 que es 1 o sea por iu y bien
entonces ya tengo mis raíces con jugadas
que quiere decir esto que entonces ya
tengo una parte a la cual le voy a
llamar lambda que es mi parte real y
tengo también otra parte a la cual le
voy a llamar new que es mi parte real
que está multiplicando a mi número
imaginario en este caso me vale 1 porque
no es el número que está multiplicando a
la y bien si ya tengo lambda y ya tengo
mi ya puedo sustituir en ecuación
general y que me va a quedar y es igual
a la menos 2 x es decir a la parte real
x x que multiplica a la primera
constante puede conocer no de mi x pero
mío es 1 entonces no queda x más de dos
veces el seno de x por qué pues porque
me vale 1 es decir que ya encontré mi
solución general de este problema en
particular pero no es lo que quiero yo
lo que quiero es mi solución particular
de este problema particular entonces
utilicemos las condiciones iniciales
70 es igual a 1 por nuestras condiciones
iniciales entonces voy a sustituir a x
por 0
cada vez que yo la beba en solución
general y que me va a quedar pues al
menos 2 por 0 pues es uno que multiplica
a la primer constante por el coseno de
cero más la segunda constante por el
seno de ser pero el seno de cero es cero
entonces se van a dios y el coseno de
cero es uno entonces lo puedo poner como
uno y uno por uno por uno pues es ese
uno entonces dada a esta condición
inicial yo ya puedo determinar a c1 c1
es uno muy bien ya tengo ese uno pues
ahora habrá que sacar hace dos pero para
sacar ese 2 voy a bajar la pantalla
porque ya está un poco amontonado esto
pues necesito derivar mi solución
general
pero antes de derivar como loco lo
primero que voy a hacer es sustituir ese
uno por uno para que mi ecuación se
simplifiquen es decir me va a quedar que
es igualdad en al menos 2 x x c 1 pero
segundos 1 entonces pues no lo pongo por
el coseno de x + c 2 por el seno de x y
lo que tenemos que determinar es c 2
ahora si derivamos a mi solución general
quien base de prima pues es la
multiplicación de dos funciones por lo
tanto voy a utilizar la derivada de la
multiplicación que es la derivada del
primero el cual ya sabemos que es menos
dos minutos x y ponemos el segundo tal
cual sin hacerle nada muy bien y ahora
lo que tengo que hacer es poner sumarle
el primero sin derivar los sin hacerle
nada y multiplicarlo por la derivada del
segundo es decir la derivada del coseno
que es el menos seno de x
más co2 y la derivada del seno de x pero
la derivada del seno es el coche no
entonces me quedan dos coseno de x
uno puede pensar que aquí podemos
simplificar o tal vez mover el coche no
de un lado y el seno del otro lado pero
lo más sencillo es utilizar la condición
inicial que ya tenemos que cuando sean
inicial teníamos se acuerdan de prima de
cero es igual a cero lo voy a escribir
aquí para que no se nos olvide de prima
de cero es igual a cero bien pues ahora
sustituyamos cero porque porque la prima
de cero voy a poner a x como 0 es igual
a 0 y me va a quedar menos 2 por 0 pero
a la 0 1 por menos 2 simple
sencillamente me va a quedar menos 2
entonces menos 2 que multiplica al
coseno de 0 pero el coche no de 0 es uno
entonces uno más de dos el seno de cero
por el seno de cero pues es cero y
entonces hasta hincha acaba todo muy
bien y ahora le voy a sumar a la 0 que a
la 01 que multiplica al menos seno
00 más de dos veces el coseno de cero
que es uno o sea de dos bien y ya si
tenemos esto yo puedo determinar hace
dos y entonces que nos queda pues nos va
a quedar que menos dos por uno es menos
dos más uno por de dos pues es de dos
bien y de que ya podemos despejar hace
dos dedos es ni más ni menos que dos muy
bien lo voy a atrapar en un cuadrito
fíjense que tengo que la primera
constante es uno y que la segunda
constante es dos bien entonces lo que
quiero hacer es es que este pizarrón
este hecho un caos
voy a voy a borrar algunas cosas porque
todo esto me está confundiendo vamos a
correr todo y hay que memorizar c1 e
igual a 1 y c 2 es igual a 2 ayudan a
memorizarlo ok bien entonces voy a
quitar todo esto para poder poner ahora
sí la solución general de una manera
grande y de una manera bonita borramos
todo esto
que habíamos dicho que la primer
constante era 1 y la segunda constante
era 2
así que utilizando ya mi expresión que
yo tenía para mi solución particular la
voy a poner de esta manera y ala menos
2x que multiplica a la primer constante
pero primera constante era igual a 1
entonces solamente me queda coseno de x
más la constante 2 que es dos veces el
seno de x muy bien ya tengo por fin mi
solución particular pero yo sí quiero
que analicemos dos cosas muy importantes
la primera es que en mis condiciones
iniciales y en ecuación diferencial de
segundo orden en mis coeficientes
constantes en ninguno salió una y y
aunque nosotros dijimos que ese 2 era un
número que podía ser imaginario en este
caso desde cuenta de que lo más
interesante es que la solución
particular no tiene
no hay lugar para la y en mi solución
particular esto nos habla de dos cosas
la primera es que como en mis
condiciones iniciales yo no tenía
ninguna condición inicial que tuviera
que ver con inning entonces suena más
lógico que mi solución particular no
tenga que ver con números imaginarios la
segunda cosa es que una ecuación
diferencial tampoco está involucrada
ninguna y y por lo tanto en ecuación
particular no debe estar involucrada
ninguna y ese sin ningún número
imaginario pero bien esto ya lo habíamos
aprendido ahora y lo que sí quiero ver
es que en el siguiente vídeo vamos a
utilizar otra vez este tipo de fórmulas
para resolver otro ejemplo que sea muy
útil en el cual tal vez puedan existir
números imaginarios pero eso ya lo
veremos la siguiente ocasión y aunque
esta vez se nos ha acabado el tiempo
pues nos vamos a ver en el siguiente
vídeo así que nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo